how close would you say is what's going
on today with the current market that we
have
to 2007 2008 what's different about it
what similar trends do we see and what
blind spots do we have that we're saying
that's not a big deal we're not in
recession it's not as bad as people make
it out to be we're going to be okay how
similar is it how different is it from
oh wait well
so
over the last really following the
financial crisis
the federal reserve and the uh and
congress and the government had to
stimulate the economy to get things
stabilized which they did and uh and
then things
uh progressed however what happened is
the fed got hooked on easy money uh
monetary policy they kept interest rates
way below the rate of inflation
they flooded the money supply into the
system so that everyone had plenty of
cash and lots of liquidity is that
quantitative easing is that no that is
well quantitative easing on top of it
and then they decided to go out and and
purchase originally about four or five
trillion dollars of treasuries and
mortgages and what that did is that bid
up the prices of those that drove down
long-term interest rates and forced
everybody into the stock market real
estate market so it caused those asset
prices to go up dramatically
so i think we are in the biggest
bubble
risk of a bubble that i've seen in my
career bigger than what it was in 2000
you believe that absolutely
if you look at what's happened in
housing
and we may have hit the speculative peak
now i don't know
but uh we try to go back and look and
see what's the long-term trend line of
what real estate should be doing
nationally
uh and uh and in
2006 it became very concerned we were
above trend line that's in in it it
looked like it was inflated by about 10
to 20 percent higher than it should be
and it appears to be more inflated today
than what it was leading into that
period
so that causes me concern the difference
today is that the stock market similarly
increased in value much greater
faster than the rate of inflation or the
or the rate of earnings growth or or the
growth in the economy so stock prices
are much more inflated today than they
were prior just prior to the financial
crisis
this time we've also seen collectibles
and other
more exotic instruments
escalate at prices that appear to be way
above their incentive when you say
collect like nfcs
paintings uh yeah uh crypto
a whole variety of things now it appears
that that bubble peaked a year ago and
so we've had some major corrections and
a lot of them you see bitcoin down
two-thirds in value and and a lot of
other things i think are starting to
self-correct itself
didn't you just say that the entire
crypto market the entire crypto market
assets are now under a trillion two
years ago just bitcoin alone was a top
of a trillion just to put that in
perspective the entire crypto market is
now under a trillion two years ago just
bitcoin alone was it truly wild yeah so
the things that concern me one is i
think the federal reserve has been way
too
aggressive and easy money policy they
kept interest rates too low too long
they flooded the system with too much
money
and the the quantitative easing of
buying assets forced asset prices up all
over the world
and then the follow-through on that is
every central bank in the world
saw what they were doing and did the
same thing so now we have the potential
risk of a global
asset bubble so this thing's not just a
u.s issue it's all over the country
including countries like china where
it's it's a whole different topic but it
it may be the greatest real estate
bubble in the history of the world is
sitting there that's what this evergreen
situation that's one reflection of it
and so that concerns me a lot about what
the fed's done and how it set us up for
a major problem and then we have the
federal government going off and
incurring the last decade about 1.7
trillion a year of budget deficits
now
some things are necessary said coming
out of the financial crisis yes of 2008
we needed to stabilize for a short
period but they got hooked on it and
we've been budget
uh deficits ever since then we hit covid
and yes i understand short-term measures
but i think we put too much stimulus for
too long and uh and that's increased our
our debt to about 30 trillion dollars
for the for the country
well when the fed keeps interest rates
too low
that also encourages everybody to go out
and borrow
so again we were talking about all the
borrowing the people went out to do on
homes and stretched on homes and all
that stuff
now it's across the board it's got
consumers businesses and governments our
government in particular
but
every government uh across uh across the
world so we have the greatest level of
debt
in the world's history we're at 300
trillion dollars of outstanding debt now
which is the greatest percent of gdp in
the history of the world
so we have a system highly levered
built on the back of assets
which i
think many key asset categories are
inflated and maybe it bubbles status
so that creates an enormous leverage
risky system and if something comes into
it
to disrupt it and we saw what kovit can
do short term but you know what what
will wars do what will cyber security
things do what would uh
political unrest or
constitutional crisis in the united
states or some of the civil unrest
things that we have and we've also set
up a country now where our
inequality is the greatest it's been
since right before the crash of the
stock market in the 20s
we are
we are approaching that kind of
inequality status and so when you think
about a country it's not just about are
we all going to do okay in the short run
you got to worry are you setting
yourself up where the very democracy
that we're built on
uh is at risk because there's such a
large percent of the population that is
being left behind in the like so i think
there's a lot of risk out there
very difficult to project if and when
that's going to happen but i found over
decades of of looking at it from an
investment side that whenever everything
gets way above trend lines
that's probably a good time to be pretty
cautious
and on the other side is you will have
periods where everything is really
attractively priced relative to those
trend lines and that's when you uh when
you really want to be aggressive on the
buy side so if i'm just doing it right
now i say this is a good time to be
cautious keep your powder dry and still
keep it dry
i would still personally i would keep it
dry particularly in real estate because
look at the numbers don't work you can't
have housing going to these record
levels where affordability is now the
the poorest
since the 80s
and interest rates probably have to
continue to go up
because
if you think there's a if you think
inflation
is going to be higher than about
two and a half percent or so maybe three
percent at the highest of on a long-term
basis interest rates don't reflect that
yet interest rates have to go up more
to if that's where we end up stabilizing
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]